The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANNALISA WEIGEL: So
let's start with--
HUGH MCMANUS: I'm Hugh
McManus, the co-creator
of the lean enterprise
value simulation.
I'm going to talk a little bit
about teaching lean thinking
principles through
hands on learning
with particular reference to
what we do in the Lean Academy.
Credited here are
Eric Rebentisch Tisch,
my co-creator in the lean
enterprise value simulation.
And Earl and Alexis, who
were key in integrating
the lean enterprise value
simulation, part of it,
into the Lean Academy.
The reason we use
simulation-based education
for this is that teaching lean
is is a difficult challenge.
A great deal of that is
because it's experience-based
and it depends on a context,
the context of existing
industrial and
engineering processes
that are not
familiar to students.
So we really need to
give them something
to think about and work with
before a lot of these ideas
start to make real
sense to them.
So we use
simulation-based education
to increase comprehension.
To allow them to put
the ideas together
in a more holistic,
way not just bits
and pieces of
technical knowledge,
but how does it
all work together?
And of course learning through
experience, getting a tactile
feel for the material.
Final thing for an intensive
event like the Lean Academy
is also just to get
the energy rubbed off.
To give them something to do.
To get their blood
pressure up a little bit.
To keep them awake and excited
and involved in the class.
The simulation is
built around attempting
to build LEGO airplanes that
are actually relatively poorly
designed LEGO airplanes, if the
criteria for a LEGO airplane
is that it's relatively
easy to put together
and it stays together
once you put it there.
This is not a very
good airplane.
And it's built in
a very unlean way.
It's built in a
legacy system which
has an unbalanced production
system with bottlenecks
and other problems.
A long supply chain.
A long and uncoordinated
supply chain.
The LEGOs actually come
from someplace else.
They have to be transported
to the table where
the airplanes are built. And
there's a lot of paperwork
and communications issues in
both getting the plane built.
And then at the
end of each round,
doing the accounting
necessary to figure out
whether you actually made
money or not from the airplane.
The system used in the Lean
Academy is moderately simple.
We have four
manufacturing plants
that build tails, fuselages,
wings, and final assembly
to deliver an airplane
to the customer.
We have a supplier
quality representative
who interacts with a
supply chain consisting
of a single dedicated supplier,
but in a different place.
At a table where
the suppliers sit.
So there's a flow of information
between these people.
And hopefully that
creates a flow of parts,
of subassemblies in
parts, that result
in some value being delivered
in aircraft being delivered
to the customer.
The simulation it's
not just a matter
of building LEGO airplanes.
It's actually a fairly
rigidly defined simulation
that has a number of features.
For one thing, each student
what they're allowed to do
is represented
visually like this.
Each student is set is
told, take these pieces
and build that assembly.
This both defines what
they need to do visually
so it's fairly easy to
understand and it's changeable.
Very important.
This is a rather difficult
assembly to put together.
If the students
wish to change it,
they can in an organized way.
The processes that
they do are also
constrained by hourglasses.
It's not a dexterity contest.
It's not a race.
It's a process.
And this process is at
many steps constrained
by the pace of some hourglasses
in particular, the assembly
operations.
Depending on the part
count, hourglasses
with different times are used
to represent the actual factory
operations that are happening.
That are simulated
by the simulation.
It's not just a matter of
the student's dexterity.
And so this becomes a
constraint that the students
have to work with and
design solutions around.
There's a fairly long paperwork
chain and it's fairly clumsy.
It's not that hard to
learn but it turns out
it's not that easy to use.
Standard paper order form here.
You could think of
that even as a web
form in the modern economy.
But you're just saying, I
want this many of this part,
handing it off to your supplier
quality representative, who
then hands it to the
supplier who has to fill it.
And then they have to fill out
essentially an invoice sheet
that they send back to you.
That means that every
transaction with LEGOs
involves two pieces of paper
and 1, 2, 3, 4 steps just
to get your parts to build.
Not a very good system but not
atypical of the real world.
And finally there's
an accounting system
for Lean Academy.
It's a cash flow system that
tracks all the costs involved.
A fixed costs.
How much does it cost to
keep your plants open?
The variable cost.
How much do those parts cost?
What does it cost to
do various things?
And you can figure out whether
you're making money or not.
Often you're not.
And if you don't get
out enough airplanes,
you don't make any money.
Or if you do things
in a wasteful way,
if you waste parts, you
won't make any money.
ANNALISA WEIGEL:
All right everybody.
Let's check in.
I'd like to find out how
many planes each table built.
Let's start here.
One plane.
AUDIENCE: One.
ANNALISA WEIGEL: One plane?
Two planes.
One plane.
All right.
Who's making money?
AUDIENCE: No one.
ANNALISA WEIGEL: Let
me ask a question.
Is anybody's manufacturing
operations making money yet?
No.
OK.
Tell me how much
money the supplier
is making whose profitable?
AUDIENCE: 14.
ANNALISA WEIGEL: 14.
OK.
So you're barely profitable.
That's better than
being negative.
All right.
So the supplier might be
doing well in that enterprise,
but it might be at the expense
of the manufacturing portion.
So this is something
that you're going
to think about as you go
through your simulation.
HUGH MCMANUS: So
in the Lean Academy
we dedicate one day to
the simulation, about 2/3
of the teaching
time in that day.
There's some lectures
interspersed.
It happens in 12
minute active rounds--
there's 12 minutes of frenzy.
Followed by on-- preceded
by in many cases, time
for reflection, planning,
financial analysis,
and so forth.
And these are separated
up into basically learning
how to do the simulation,
getting past the learning
curve.
Understanding how lean
process improvements can
be used to take a legacy state
and make it lean and make it
work better.
And then a final round where
the manufacturing suppliers
and also a not simulated, but
conceptual engineering process,
is used to achieve enterprise
lean by redesigning
the airplane, tuning the supply
chain to a really high state,
and seeing what you can do
in an almost ideal state.
ANNALISA WEIGEL: This is a
common tool around the industry
to go and look at
other facilities
and benchmark yourselves not
only with respect to companies
that do the same thing as
you do, but also to benchmark
yourself against companies
that do other things
but have similar
processes to you.
So there's a lot to learn
by going and walking
around and seeing this.
And from what I took
away from the tables,
I think we've got two different
build-to philosophies going on.
So you'll notice
there are two kinds
of build-to packages going on.
Just take a look at
that and see what
cause somebody else to think
differently than what you did.
I also wanted you guys to
notice this table here.
Because I saw you guys.
You flipped your
bins upside down when
you are ready for a new ones.
That was your signals?
AUDIENCE: This wasn't,
we don't want anymore.
This is, we do.
ANNALISA WEIGEL: And
that's you do want more.
So I saw that and I thought that
was an interesting practice.
Anybody else have a
practice that worked well
for them that might not
come out when you're
doing your table tours and just
looking at the static display?
AUDIENCE: The clock [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: We used one
timer for all four of us.
AUDIENCE: Oh no.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: No.
Then we're all synchronized.
We're all--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ANNALISA WEIGEL: So there's
a best practice that you
might consider adopting.
Did we have a comment
from this team here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We color coded our
bins and then color
coded our standard
order sheets so
that she would be able
to identify more quickly.
ANNALISA WEIGEL: OK, so
did everybody hear that?
There's color coding
of bins and color
coding of the different
standard orders
to try to match
visual inspection
and get quality good.
AUDIENCE: We also color coded.
So the red bin goes here.
[INAUDIBLE]
ANNALISA WEIGEL: So they
have three marks of color
to try to get that
all coordinated.
Other best practices
that won't come out again
if you're just looking around?
AUDIENCE: Yes, we did a
continuous delivery cycles up
until we're done.
Because we noticed that there
was variability on how long
it took to fill the bin.
[INAUDIBLE]
ALLEN HAGGERTY: The Lean
Aerospace Initiative,
which funded all
this stuff years ago,
is the consortium
of all the aerospace
companies and the government.
And in these conferences
that we have,
the suppliers, the
engineers, the manufacturers
would get up and make
presentations to basically show
how they do things.
And that's the benefit of this--
makes the benchmarking a lot
easier because people basically
put their heads together
and everybody benefits.
I mean there's an annual
fee that the companies pay
that supports all that.
But they in fact get
the advantages of--
gee, we took a tour
through so many factory
and they going a red light that
goes on or something like that.
So all the aerospace companies
benefit from the conversation
and the discussion
and the presentations
and the factory tours of
each other's organization.
HUGH MCMANUS: The
tools that they
use include simple
organization, which
they can use lean principles
like 5S and visual control
to clean up their workplace.
Just get the basic
process working.
OK?
Balancing a workload.
Which can be planned
around lean principles
like pack time,
single piece flow.
Which essentially allows them
to move work between plants
to clear bottlenecks and
get the work balanced.
They can tear down
or move facilities.
Again, based on lean principles,
not just random action.
And they can modernize
this archaic order system.
Again, planned using
lean principles.
And there's a mechanic in
the simulation to allow
a paperless-- there's actually
still a little bit of paper
but much less--
ordering system that would
simulate a modern web-based
perhaps, or certainly
electronics-based
inventory management system.
One of the key features
is the simulation
allows us is to use data.
It's very difficult to go out
to a real aircraft manufacturing
plant and play with it.
With the simulation, we can
play with it in these 12 minute
rounds and create and
use data that we've
collected to both plan
improvements and track
processes.
So we can keep track of how
long does it take to do things?
How many parts are involved?
What's the delay involved in
ordering parts, et cetera?
And we can do that
quantitatively and that's
one of the key aspects of most
product improvement techniques.
It's to use the data
and let it tell you
what to do, not just make
things up as you go along.
Be entirely dependent
on common sense
or experience to do these
kinds of improvements.
And this data can
be incorporated
into classic lean tools
like value-stream mapping.
This is the same data plotted
in the classic lean value-stream
map.
Again it gives them the
opportunity to touch a tool,
to actually use it, to actually
fill out the data with data
that they've collected from
at least a simulated reality
and then use that to
analyze it, so that they
can find bottlenecks.
They can find
non-value added steps.
They can find places
where paperwork and lack
of synchronization are
slowing the process down
and then focus their
improvements on those areas.
Finally at the end
of the simulation,
we essentially, as we do in the
real world with lean thinking,
ask them to expand
their horizons.
Expand the boundaries
of the enterprise
that they're
considering and seeing
if they can get bigger
payoffs by doing more.
By bringing in more functions.
In this case, there's not
an engineering function
in the simulation, but we
do allow them to redesign
the airplane to cut part count.
Reduce part types.
Fix problems with the airplane.
Make it easier to assemble.
Do all of the things--
all of the engineering
functions that facilitate
lean in the real world.
And again, touch it, understand
it, understand it in context,
and then see how it
works in the final round.
And again, by rebalancing work,
by redesigning the airplane,
by changing the facility
organization and further model
modernizing the supply
chain, by getting
into a really clean modern
just-in-time supply chain.
Using the lean principles
and implementing it
on the simulation, they can
get an outstanding process out
of it.
And that gives them a real
intuitive and tactile feel
for how lean type product
improvement principles can
be used to not just
make a process better,
but to make it astonishingly
better in a way
that they usually do
not think is possible
when they start the simulation.
Another thing that's done is
throughout the simulation,
we embed learning by
doing mini lessons.
And this is just
a single example.
Kanban systems.
Kanbans are a inventory
management ordering
and transport system which
is difficult to lecture
to because it's a very simple
thing that does a lot of-- that
has a lot of different
functionalities
in the real world.
And solves a lot of problems
in ways that are sometimes
not intuitive.
In the simulation, they use
Kanbans to basically solve
their inventory management
and supply chain problems.
And they get both repeated
reintroduction to the concept
and what they're doing,
and mentored execution
of that concept in
the simulated world,
so that they really do get
an understanding of how
a simple system like Kanban
can serve so many functions
and solve some problems.
The overall result--
and this is typical data
from a real event
is that they can
go from producing no
airplanes, or maybe one,
the first time they try.
To producing a dozen the
last time, in the same time
and using the same
basic capabilities.
They never get to throw
the hourglasses away.
It never turns into
a LEGO building race.
This isn't just
a learning curve.
What they've done is
the process as it exists
and made it much, much better.
And tracking along with
that is the financials,
which go from losing a lot
of money to making a lot.
Not surprisingly,
but again, they
get a feel for how this kind
of production efficiency
can lead to financial
performance.
OK, so we had a
successful conclusion
of our simulation exercise.
All of our tables
managed to produce
at least eight aircraft.
One table got all
the way up to the 12
that the customer really wanted.
And we had an 11 and a 10.
Everybody got there by a
somewhat different route
and we learned some
lessons along the way.
Our group that produced eight.
Now that was still better
than the theoretical maximum
six they were making before.
But they didn't meet the
theoretical capacity of 12
because they still hadn't ironed
out issues with their supply
chain and with coordinating.
It wasn't that they didn't
have the theoretical capacity,
it was that the coordination
of the different components
of their enterprise wasn't
completely ironed out yet.
So they didn't meet
their production goals.
Very interesting.
The group that made 11 airplanes
did get everything coordinated.
They did a very good job.
One order.
One order was one piece short.
And in a lean system, you're
very vulnerable to that kind
of disruption.
That one order.
That one piece in that
one order cost them
an airplane,
because it disrupted
their synchronization.
It took them a
minute to recover.
That was an airplane.
Still that is a known issue with
lean production systems, not
necessarily a bad thing.
That the issue--
the problem that
caused the one order to be
bad was surfaced immediately.
And in the future--
that happened actually
early in the round and
they didn't do it again.
And of course they achieved
11, which is a lot better
than seven aircraft.
And we had one group that
was hitting on all cylinders
and managed to produce
the aircraft a minute
that the customers
really wanted.
Interestingly too, if
we look over the course
of the whole day, the
production-- a little bit
of variation.
Basically everybody's improving
production as they go along.
The financial results show
some interesting detail.
It's harder to see in
the production diagram.
Which is that although
everybody's profit improved,
people took different paths.
And this has been a
great class for this
because basically the paths
that people took pretty much
mirror the kinds of things that
can happen in the real world
when you go into
improvement events.
Group number one started
out losing a lot of money.
As soon as they stabilized
their traditional process,
they actually managed
to make money.
And when they disrupted
it, trying to lean it out.
They had what we call
a worse-before-better.
Things actually got worse
until they got better again
and stabilized at a
high profit situation.
Group number two showed a much
steadier increase in profit.
They basically showed an
almost linear improvement.
So they were not so
disrupted by change.
Didn't come to quick results,
but by learning slowly
and steadily as they went
through the transformation
process, managed to increase
their profits steadily.
That's nice because
that looks good.
It's not always what happens.
The green te-- sorry,
blue team, showed again,
a typical reaction.
They stabilized and then in
the actual improvement round,
the round where
they changed things,
showed at best steady
financial results.
So this was learning
in a given state
but they would have
maxed out there.
During the transformation
they didn't make more money,
but that set them up
for the next round
where they made a lot.
And again during the
next transformation
they flattened off again.
This is a lot nicer than
that worse-before-better,
but it's still very typical.
While you're investing
the resources.
While you're changing things.
You can't expect the
dramatic financial results
to happen right away.
What you do is set yourself
up for dramatic improvements
in the next period.
And we had a final
group which also did
the worse-before-better thing.
It had a little bit
of a unfortunate end
result, which is the very
last round they actually
had it worse.
And that was the group that
only made the eight aircraft.
They were quite certain if we'd
done another round that they
could have gotten
the 12 and in fact
completed their zig-zag
worse-before-better journey.
So that's a description of the
simulation and how it's used.
We're going to do
a brief description
of the pedagogical
goals of the simulation
and how we think they've been
achieved in the Lean Academy
context.
We said that we wanted it to
increase the comprehension
of the curriculum.
And there is some literature
evidence that this works.
In particular, in the
computer world people
have played computer games
versus static computer
websites.
And it has been shown
that the little games--
and these are little toy games.
But the little games
basically make people retain
the material much better.
And also if you
look at behavior.
There's been studies on
things like healthy diet
that people that have learned
through game-based learning as
opposed to static learning
actually take-- not only learn
and retain the information,
better but it actually
affects the outcome.
So that's good.
That evidence is there.
We also hoped that there's
better understanding
of the context and the holistic
nature of the material.
And we hoped that they
learn through experience.
That it engages different
learning modes and that
it allows them to
practice field,
to actually touch
and use the ideas.
These are supported as goals.
But there's not really a whole
lot of scientific evidence
that this works.
Intuitively, the evidence
is pretty powerful
and the anecdotal experience
from the students is powerful.
It's not a proven outcome.
And we can certainly
say that we've
observed greatly
increased student
involvement and excitement.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, when we were
on the same team for the LEGO
simulation and it
was a lot of fun.
Especially since we got
a little competitive
with the other teams and trying
to build the most airplanes.
But that was really cool.
It's something that
we played with ever
since we were little
kids and to be
able to build something but
then apply the lean principles.
And it was really amazing
to see how much we
learned through that.
AUDIENCE: It was
probably the best way
of demonstrating
how process that I
thought it was efficient at
first and after applying lean.
We didn't think we could make
12 airplanes in 12 minutes
but well-- we almost made it.
We made 10.
But it is possible
to do what some
believe is impossible at first.
And after applying the analysis
and getting all the processes
down correctly, we were
getting pretty close.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I mean
that's pretty amazing.
I was looking at the chart up
there and I was like, wait.
We really only made one in
12 minutes the first time?
And then went all
the way up to 10 so.
AUDIENCE: We're impressed.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
HUGH MCMANUS: So we
think this is working.
We also have had very positive
experience with basically
teaching complicated systems.
Most of the previous
literature evidence
was on relatively simple things.
Fact-based things.
We're actually trying
to teach a system that
affects other systems.
So it's a complicated
body of knowledge,
body of understanding,
that the students
are expected to absorb in
a relatively short time.
And most of these
systems are not
available for manipulation
for teaching purposes.
You can't go play with
an airplane factory.
We found that the students
have a good experience--
and this experience
is not limited
to this particular
simulation, although this
is a good exemplar of it.
If the simulation is complex
enough to capture the key
features, including the emergent
behaviors of the system.
If it's too simple, you're
not really changing anything.
You're not really
changing a system that
has unexpected
behaviors, so you're not
going to capture this
kind of learning.
On the other hand, it
has to be simple enough
to have an acceptable
learning curve.
If it takes three
days to learn it's not
going to be a teaching tool.
And of course, it has to
be fast enough that you
can do multiple cycles of
learning within the teaching
period.
It also has to be
credible in the sense
that it can't have artifacts
that the students say,
well, this is not
realistic and therefore I
will dismiss the experience
because I don't believe it.
And it has to be fun
to keep people engaged.
And basically on
this set of criteria,
we think that the simulation
that we use in the Lean Academy
is pretty good.
Students think it's
pretty good too.
This is feedback from
about 200 students,
194 students over a couple
of years of Lean Academies.
And we consistently
get the highest score
of the types of learning,
both other active learning
and lecturing materials.
That the Lean Academy simulation
provides positive reinforcement
of the concepts.
That's the wording
of the question
and the students agree
that that's the case.
Just qualitatively we also
get some written feedback
and verbal feedback.
And it appears, and
again this is unprompted.
We asked them the
general question,
what do you like
about the course
and what do you don't like?
And what we find
is what they like
is what we're hoping,
which is that it increases
the comprehension
of the curriculum.
That the hands-on learning
and practice field experiences
are valuable to them.
And that it increases their
involvement and excitement
with the material.
As well as-- this
was not an explicit,
but it does show up a lot
in the student responses
as a team building and
camaraderie building activity.
It's also very effective.
And this is just a
numerical breakdown
of those kinds of responses.
Out of 106 written responses,
we got a lot of illuminatings.
A fair number of, we
liked the hands-on aspect.
And the excitement and bonding
were somewhat secondary
but mentioned.
As well as a big blob is
just generic, we like it.
But that doesn't tell us a whole
bunch about why they like it
but these do and it's
what we're hoping.
Caveats.
Always important.
This evaluation is based
on satisfaction, not really
outcomes.
We don't track the
students in their careers
as aerospace engineer so we
don't have outcome metrics yet.
It's cost and time intensive
to do this kind of thing.
You need trained facilitators.
It takes money to
set up a facility
to do this, couple
of thousand dollars.
That's the startup cost.
Not the per each,
although you do
have to pay these
people somehow.
They're vulnerable
to disruption.
Logistics, facility, failure
to keep on schedule errors
can degrade the
experience badly.
Our simulation seems
to be fairly robust
but in general simulations
are vulnerable to disruption.
And you can't satisfy
every learning style.
Amusingly, we've
had written feedback
asking for both more
and last simulation.
Because some people
feel they need more time
to internalize the
information that's there.
Others get it quickly and
wish they could move on
to other learning modes.
And another one, and it's
a unexpected psychological
effect, is that
there's real stress
in the simulated process.
And that this sometimes
creates difficulties
with people's learning.
Could create competition
and bad feeling
if it's not managed carefully.
We've learned that that's
something that is an issue that
needs to be managed.
And these, by the way,
are typical issues
for teaching simulations.
Conclusion to this part.
We have a unique simulation
of aerospace enterprises.
A subset of it is used
in the Lean Academy.
We think it works
and it provides
a laboratory for experiential
learning of complex systems.
There's not a whole lot of
work in this area going on.
We've had a very good
experience with it.
Certainly the feedback that
we have from our students
indicates that it's successful.
And the caveats that we
have for our simulation
are typical of learning
simulations in general.
ERIC REBENTISCH: There are other
aspects of the simulation that
replicate the entire
enterprise and I'm
going to talk a little bit
about each of those elements.
And the simulations
are modular so you
can go through the
manufacturing part
or you can go through
the engineering part,
depending on what the learning
objectives for the course are.
You can combine them
in various ways.
You can combine
the manufacturing
with the engineering to
teach specific lessons
about transition to production
and engineering support.
You can look at just
engineering alone
if you are interested
in understanding
how engineering processes
behave in a highly
variable environment.
So there's a lot of
flexibility that's
built into the
simulation environment.
So this is the simulation
that you all experience here
in the Academy that has
a manufacturing core
simulation and a
simplified supplier
base with a representative.
If you expand out to the
full supplier simulation,
you get a much richer
experience of understanding
how ordering and
fulfillment processes are
dynamic in the enterprise.
And learning much more about
network organization structures
and the way they behave and
how effective coordination is
critical to lean.
For the full enterprise,
you can add the dynamics
of an engineering system that
is supporting the manufacturing
and supply base.
And this is the full
[INAUDIBLE] sim,
where the engineering
changes that you
made during the course of
the redesign of the airplane
were done for essentially
free in this simulation
that you did in
the Lean Academy.
In the real
enterprise simulation,
you have to wait
for the engineers
to process those jobs.
And that can lead to all
sorts of interesting dynamics
amongst the players and
simulated organizational
structures.
There's also a
service and support
module that looks at aftermarket
field support for the products
and this introduces new and
interesting complexities
to the enterprise.
Because you now
have two main value
streams and sources of revenues.
You have to prioritize
where you make
improvements in the enterprise.
All right.
So there's another
variant of the simulation
that focuses on just an
engineering organization.
Most engineering organizations
have multiple projects
going on at a given
time and they're
competing for resources.
And those projects
aren't always the same.
So this simulation looks at
how you prioritize projects,
how you structure the
organization, how you manage
the interactions so
that you get the highest
throughput through the
system and the most
return on investment
for improvements
through lean practices.
So some of the things that we're
not covered in the Lean Academy
simulation are a more
advanced economic system
that allows you to
make trade-offs,
to understand what the impact
of lean improvements are,
and to actually calculate
financial performance
of the kind that
you would typically
track with a real company.
There's also a lean
calculator that
can be used to evaluate whether
one proposed improvement
effort is better than another.
And these are levels
of analysis that
are more in-depth tools, that
are more sophisticated that
can be added on to
the sim environment.
So in all, it's a fairly
sophisticated system
for teaching the impact of
lean principles and practices
on an enterprise.
So there are a number
of organizations
that are using the web
simulation and its variants
and they have adopted
it for their own use
and are actually using it in
their own internal training.
So we have a method for actually
disseminating these materials.
And if there are any questions
about adopting the simulation,
the best place to
go would be to send
a message to ednet@mit.edu.
And you can get more
information about how you might
adopt these training materials.